hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled sars kovi ii neutralizing
antibody testing for vaccine efficacy
assessment this webinar is part of the
clinical diagnostics research event and
i am susie valdez of labyrinths and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
gen scripts for more information about
our sponsor please visit them at
genscripts.com
now let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate first by communicating with
other attendees using our new live chat
feature during the presentation you can
find that live chat located at the right
hand side of your screen
state by submitting as many questions as
you want during the presentation to do
so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you will also notice that the speaker
has provided a survey located at the
right of the abstract this survey will
be available during both the live
session and the on-demand period now if
you have any trouble seeing or hearing
this presentation just click on the help
desk button located at the bottom of
your screen within the navigation bar or
from the lobby and finally as a reminder
this presentation is educational and
offers free continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the abstract
window below the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain those
credits i now present today's speaker dr
sean taylor north american field
application scientist manager at gen
script usa for a complete biography of
our speakers please visit the biography
tab at the top left of your screen dr
taylor welcome you may now begin your
presentation
hello everyone this is sean taylor field
application scientist manager for jen
script in north america
and now that we have reached a stage
where
multiple global populations have been
vaccinated by a variety of different
vaccines
a new approach to testing
may be required in this pre and post
vaccination era so some critical
questions surrounding the sars cove to
pandemic have arisen and the first one
is associated with the commercial
vaccines themselves which have widely
different efficacies begging the
question
how am i assured protection
post-vaccination in the concept in the
context of the wild type and variance
strains that are circulating now with
varying vaccine efficacies
the second question
is associated with the persistence of
immunity
when i get vaccinated
how long am i actually immune before i
potentially need a booster shot
and the third question is
related to the first two questions what
tests are relevant and provide the most
actionable information in populations of
mixed vaccinated and non-vaccinated
individuals there are two major
categories of testing one being serology
which are antibody based tests
and molecular which are the
uh rna slash dna based tests to assess
the live virus circulating so the
serology tests are the signature of the
virus
after being either infected or
vaccinated with an immune response and
then antibodies that are generated
within the host consequent to steroscope
to infection or vaccination
the
molecular testing is really to assess
the presence of live virus the the
presence of active infection early on
after
the infection has begun
but once the immune response has taken
over the viral rna levels go way down
because the immune system has responded
and attacked the virus and destroyed the
virus and prevented
the virus from reinfecting cells and
what we're left with are the signature
of the virus
from the immune response which are the
antibodies now that are circulating to
sars cove too amongst all the antibodies
that are generated in immune response
there's a very special subclass of
antibodies which are called
neutralization antibodies and these
antibodies have a very
defined function in blocking the virus
from docking to the host cell so in a
sars cove ii infection the spike protein
the tip of the spike protein which is
called the receptor binding domain
interacts with the host cell
ace2 receptor so the extracellular
domain of what's called the ace2
receptor in a host cell so this would be
the lipid bilayer membrane of a host
cell and this would be the ace2 receptor
so this is the intracellular part and
this is the extracellular part which
interacts with the receptor binding
domain
of the spike protein
of cyrus cove2 so it's a very strong
interaction and when the virus binds or
docks to the h2 receptor
it can then
inject its rna into the host cell to
make more viral particles so this is
what
propagates infection so if we can block
the virus by the binding of antibodies
to that tip of the spike protein to the
receptor binding domain then the virus
can't bind to the h2 receptor and
therefore will not be able to replicate
and propagate infection so the virus is
essentially rendered inert
unable to propagate infection so these
neutralizing antibodies are what
promote or prevent the virus from
actually binding to the ac2 receptor
and as we see here with this dart board
if the dart board represents the spike
protein let's say
and all these darts represent antibodies
that are generated by the immune
response we can see that
the
antibodies none of these antibodies are
hitting anywhere near the spike protein
itself there's a lot of antibodies being
generated but
they're not neutralizing
as we as we zoom in on the dart board we
can see oh in fact that some antibodies
actually are towards the spike protein
and there's one in particular this green
arrow which is right in the bullseye and
that's that's a neutralizing antibody
which would bind to the receptor binding
domain so as i mentioned
in the immune response many antibodies
are made the
the immune system doesn't know
what
and how to make a neutralizing antibody
it just makes a whole bunch of
antibodies but some of them are
neutralizing and those are the important
ones because they block the virus
so
ideally we would be testing for
neutralizing antibodies then in in the
immune response to either infection or
vaccination because those are the
antibodies that really are the ones that
are important in blocking and preventing
infection
now there are some some
pre-existing
neutralization tests that are out there
that test for neutralizing antibodies
and and both of them require
either live sars cove two virus or a
pseudovirus that expresses
the uh the spike protein of sars cove
two so this is a safer test because this
is just an innocuous virus that makes
just the spike protein so we can use
this in a bsl2 lab however if we're
using a virus neutralization test with
live virus then this is very dangerous
obviously we don't want to get infected
with seroscope too so it requires uh
biosafety level three laboratory
containment facility which is uh
not they're not that common and they
also require very special training and
equipment to work in that kind of an
environment
both of these types of tests require a
significant amount of time to run the
test to assess neutralizing antibodies
in a patient sample so in a blood sample
typically two to four days of work using
live cells and live cell culture and
live virus and culturing virus which is
all very time consuming and requires
specialized training
so
gen script released a novel
assay
that uses not live virus or live cells
but the protein components of the virus
and cell that interact with each other
so as i mentioned
the interacting components are the
receptor binding domain of the spike
protein of the virus so the very tip of
the spike protein is the receptor
binding domain
and the extracellular domain of the ace2
receptor
depicted here in pink
so we teased out these protein
components and expressed them and
purified them
uh so that we have in green here the
ace2 the site the extracellular domain
of the ace2 receptor
and the receptor binding domain of the
virus and we tested these two proteins
to confirm in fact that even
when separated when taken
when expressed individually that they do
interact very strongly so they complex
together very strongly so they mimic
this interaction between the live virus
and the host cell
so by coding elisa plates with the ace2
receptor as we've done here
then all we need to do is incubate the
receptor binding domain
depicted here this protein
with patient samples
and if those samples contain
neutralizing antibodies as we see here
depicted in red then those neutralizing
antibodies can will bind very strongly
to the receptor binding domain protein
and block it from binding to the h2
receptor there will be no color change
in the assay
however
if an individual doesn't have
neutralizing antibodies so you see here
the red ones are neutralizing but the
blue ones they still bind somewhere on
the receptor binding domain but they're
non-neutralizing they're they're
non-functional so they
they permit
the receptor binding domain to interact
with the ac2 receptor as we see here
and if the if this interaction happens
then the color of the solution
uh turns yellow and the darker the color
of less neutralizing antibodies are in
the patient sample the advantage of this
test uh apart from the fact that it's
now an elisa test with protein
components that permits this to be very
high throughput
uh
much more high throughput than any of
the live virus tests that are out there
and much less expensive than those tests
as well
is that it's immunoglobulin agnostic as
well so this test
doesn't
have any specificity for the subclasses
of immunoglobulins like iga igg igm etc
any immunoglobulin that has a
neutralizing antibody component to it
will bind to the receptor binding domain
and block it from binding to the ac2
receptor and will measure neutralization
so it's a it's a very sensitive test
because it's not limited to a specific
immunoglobulin the second advantage
is that the receptor binding domain is
in solution
and this is a big advantage because this
assures that the receptor binding domain
is in a near native conformation which
assures that the receptor binding domain
antigenic sites are very close to those
that would be found in the live virus
forcing the antibodies that are
generated to bind very specifically to
the receptor binding domain
and the third
key advantage to this test of course is
that it is a
functional assay it only measures the
functional neutralizing antibodies that
block the interaction between sars cov2
and the ace2 receptor which are the
important antibodies required for
protection
we did
do a recent study this year 2021
actually which we published in journal
of clinical microbiology
that
compared our c-pass surrogate virus
neutralization test
to other
binding antibody tests and when i say
binding antibody tests i mean
tests that do not delineate between
neutralizing antibodies and all the
other antibodies that are made
in an immune response which simply binds
somewhere to the virus but may not be
neutralizing and in those comparisons
we found that our c-pass test was very
comparable in terms of in terms of
specificity and sensitivity either equal
or had much higher specificity or
sensitivity to the other commercial
tests that were used in this study and
you can review this study too to learn
more information on this
we also compared
the test to the gold standard live virus
test
and what we found was that there was
excellent correlation to those tests uh
upwards of 98 to 99 correlation
another study compared the sars cove to
surrogate virus test or c-pass test
to
live virus tests again
in a variety of samples so you can use
it to look at neutralizing antibodies
generated in any
type of organism so long as it was
infected with sars cove ii
to assess the neutralizing antibody
response and in in fact in this study
there were there was a over 400 human
samples
and the correlation between our c-pass
surrogate virus test and
live virus prnt testing which is plaque
reducing neutralization test which is
one of the gold standards of the gold
standard live cell tests was
approximately 99
sensitivity and specificity now we have
um
released a new protocol for
semi-quantitative analysis
of the neutralization antibodies
generated from infection or vaccination
this is only for research use only that
the kit has been fda authorized for
qualitative analysis
to assess
uh positive or negative samples for
neutralization antibodies
this is to assess
the levels of neutralizing antibodies
between samples i'm not going to go into
the details of of of the actual protocol
but suffice to say that it requires
generating a standard curve from a uh
from a standard
antibody that we provide uh that can be
purchased separately with the kit so
this this is to produce the standard
curve
and then you can plot on that standard
curve the od of a given sample to assess
the titer of the sample so if we look at
the the all the different vaccines that
are out there that are commercialized
and there are many other ones since
since this was published but just to
give an example uh the efficacy versus
the original strain the original uh sars
cove ii strain that
initiated
um the pandemic way back in 2019
pfizer was 95 effective and the moderna
was 94 effective
they never were able at that time to
test their vaccines against the variants
because the variants didn't exist at
that stage so all the data we had were
these results when the johnson johnson
vaccine came out though the south
african variant was actually prevalent
and they did do some clinical trials in
south africa to assess
efficacy and we can see that against the
original strain
it's 72 which is much lower actually
than than the modern and pfizer but even
lower at 57 percent in the presence of
the of the south african strain of the
virus so so this is concerning obviously
for someone who who might receive this
vaccine same thing for the astrazeneca
vaccine where you can see that the
overall efficacy is 70 percent
against the original strain
but in south africa
there was only a 10 efficacy and they
actually stopped using the astrozenic
vaccine as a consequence of this it was
if it was as if no one was actually
getting any protection from vaccination
if we go
down the list further we can see that
the cinevac vaccine only has 50 efficacy
to the original strain
so if we look at all these data combined
again it begs the question if i receive
a certain vaccine
am i really protected post-vaccination
more real-world efficacy data which is a
little bit concerning is the elderly and
immunocompromised individuals and these
two studies here are
one was a study in germany performed on
people that were under 60 and over 80
years old and what we see here is if we
look at the negative cut off from the
from the serology test that they did
what they found was that many of the of
the people that were over 80 years old
were falling in this
not generating any significant
uh antibodies post
full vaccination
and this
this study used the pfizer vaccine and
these were all people who were fully
vaccinated uh where they where they
determined that that about 30 percent of
people over the the
over 80 years of age
don't generate measurable levels
of neutralizing antibodies in
another study which was performed in
canada and toronto
this was looking at immunocompromised
patients who are on immunosuppressive
drugs
after solid organ transplant and what
they found in this study was that over
70 percent of immunocompromised patients
receiving the modern vaccine did not
elicit a neutralizing antibody response
again this is very concerning it's not
very surprising because they were on
immunosuppressive
therapy so the immune system is already
compromised when they receive the
vaccine but still very concerning that
such a large proportion of people who
are on immunosuppressive therapy
are not having
a robust neutralizing antibody response
after vaccination
three major studies correlate vaccine
efficacy and protection so these are
very new studies that looked at vaccine
efficacy
versus
the neutralizing antibody levels in
those
individuals and
what these studies all find is that
there is a
kind of a cut off titer
somewhere around 100 to 200
wh international unit the
tighter the vaccine efficacy seems to
drop quite precipitously and and all of
these studies that have been done kind
of correlate uh each other uh pretty
well actually considering the large
variability uh in in in these studies
the corey paper also published in nature
medicine uh found that at a at 54
international units
protection is down to about 50
so again
quite well correlating with
each other all of these studies
so now if we look at
the comparison between binding assays
remember binding assays look at all the
antibodies that have been generated
by an immune response to a particular
antigen like receptor binding domain or
nucleocapsid protein or full spike
protein and if we compare those assays
to the neutralizing antibody test uh the
c-pass test that we've that we've
released
what we thought what we found was that
for two of these tests which are just
looking at igg binding
that
after using the pfizer vaccine
after two weeks
post uh the first injection of the
pfizer vaccine it looks like all the
patients almost 100 of them have a
strong antibody response but if you
compare those two immunoglobulin
binding tests to our neutralization test
which is this bought this bar in dark
blue we see we see a significant
difference much
less
people in the study group have
neutralizing antibodies in comparison to
the people that have binding antibodies
and with the moderna vaccine looking at
a more elderly population of course the
results are lower as expected because
elderly people tend to have a less
robust immune response to begin with
but
that said if you compare the
immunoglobulin binding antibody test to
the neutralization test you see a marked
decrease in
the number of people that have
neutralizing antibodies versus binding
antibodies
so it begs the question
should we be
more careful about the testing we do and
measure neutralizing antibodies to
assure which individuals have protective
neutralizing antibodies as opposed to
knowing that people just have binding
antibodies this article
where they looked at four individuals
and found that before the first
sorry after the first dose of vaccine
which is here
leading up to the second dose there was
a very low level of neutralizing
antibody titers
but
right at the second dose which is in
this gray zone here when all these
people got their second dose all these
lines go up as you see in tighter so so
very robust response
in in immunity after the second dose
which is good so lots of neutralizing
antibodies but then we measured uh their
response after the second dose and saw
that the titers dropped in some cases
quite precipitously so for patient 156
in other cases a little more gradually
so
it really does depend on
[Music]
response
how these titers drop and we still don't
know what level of titer can be a good
predictor of when to get a booster shot
but for sure the immune response
in terms of neutralizing antibody levels
is decreasing um
significantly after the second dose as
we see here
if we look at the case for israel which
which was one of the first countries to
actually receive a vaccination from the
from the pfizer vaccine
we know in in their case that
they
entered a fourth wave
of uh cases in august and that wave was
was as big as any of their other waves
and this was after their population had
been almost fully vaccinated with the
pfizer vaccine
so
there's definitely an issue of waning
immunity over time and particularly in
the presence of the variant so so most
of the
of their cases were from the delta
variant in this case
and they they initiated a booster
program and now their case load is
dropping down again almost to zero the
uk is now very much still in their
fourth wave
uh with again highly vaccinated
population pretty early on
and and again this suggests that the
immunity from that astrazeneca vaccine
is waning to the point where
people are now more susceptible
to the variant strains that are
circulating in the uk and the question
is is there a way now
to be more
um
more precise about measuring this like
when
people would need a booster shot as
opposed to as opposed to just
determining a random time frame for
people to be
to be boosted
so in conclusion
pcr testing only represents a moment in
time
when we get tested with a pcr test we
only know that we're negative at the
moment that we took the test
it doesn't mean that we are assured of
protection at any time after being
tested we could easily be infected at
any moment after a pcr test
the presence of binding antibodies also
does not mean that functional
neutralizing antibodies are present
we've we've learned this from the
previous study
here where we see that
you can have a lot of binding antibodies
but no neutralizing antibodies
furthermore a neutralizing
antibody can persist for months and
possibly longer as we saw from here
these are days after infection so this
after several months neutralizing
antibodies are still circulating in
these in in these patients
so a positive neutralizing
antibody test can indicate a persistent
level of frontline functional antibodies
that can potentially block the virus
from propagating and docking and
entering cells and propagating infection
so given that vaccine efficacy varies
widely a c-pass test may help to assure
that the expected
response to vaccination was elicited
and neutralizing antibodies can also be
measured longitudinally as we saw here
we can measure them over time to to
assess
how the antibody levels are waning and
whether protection
is still assured
so therefore for mixed vaccinated and
unvaccinated populations a combined
approach may be the best way to go about
testing now in this
post-vaccination
era
where we use pcr for those who don't
have immunity or have not been
vaccinated
and we can use c-pass or neutralizing
antibody tests for vaccinated
individuals or people who may have been
previously infected
to assess their levels of neutralizing
antibodies for more information we have
recently published a very short review
article in the journal of clinical
virology plus it's only a two and a half
page read it's it's written in very uh
plain language uh very well referenced
with the latest references and i
strongly recommend this article
as to put on your reading list
if you'd like to learn more about
anything related to this talk
and i appreciate your time and attention